>> Sean: OH, THEN IT'S IMPORTANT
SOURCES AND METHODS BUT NOT NOW.
TONIGHT'S BRIEF HANNITY HISTORY
LESSON.
THE CURRENT DOJ RULES OVER THE
REPORT'S RELEASE -- BY THE WAY,
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL HAS FULL
CONTROL.
HE DECIDES, NOBODY ELSE.
THEY WERE WIDELY BACKED BY THE
DEMOCRATS.
REMEMBER?
TWO DECADES AFTER AFTER THE
STARR REPORT WAS RELEASED.
WHAT THE DEMOCRATS WANTED IS
DESIGNED TO MAKE THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL MORE ACCOUNTABLE TO THE
PUBLIC.
THE SAME PEOPLE THAT WANTED TO
LIMIT THE RELEASE FOLLOWING
STARR'S FINDS ARE PUSHING FOR
THE FULL REPORT.
THE DEMOCRATICS ARE NOW TAKING
STEPS TO ISSUING SUBPOENA'S FOR
MUELLER'S REPORT AND THEY WANT
GRAND JURY INTERVIEWS AND
MATERIALS, WHICH WOULD BE
ILLEGAL LAST TIME I CHECKED.
JOINING US FOR THE LATEST HOUSE
FREEDOM CAUCUS, MARK MEADOWS.
ALSO, ALAN DERSHOWITZ IS BACK
WITH US.
LET ME START WITH YOU,
PROFESSOR.
LAST TIME I CHECKED,
RELEASING -- SOMEBODY IS CALLING
FOR ONE OF YOU.
RELEASING GRAND JURY
MATERIALS -- PROFESSOR
DERSHOWITZ.
HELLO, CAN I HELP YOU?
BEFORE RELEASING GRAND JURY --
IT'S ILLEGAL, CORRECT?
REDACTIONS FOR SOURCES AND
METHODS FOR PEOPLE THAT ARE
INNOCENT IN THIS, THAT WOULD BE
NORMAL BUT BARR DOES VICE
PRESIDENT TO REVEAL A THING,
DOES HE?
>> NO.
THERE'S NOTHING IN THE
REGULATIONS THAT REQUIRE HIM TO
REVEAL ANYTHING.
THE BEST TEST IS THE SHOE ON THE
OTHER FOOT TEST.
WHEN WE GO BACK TO COMEY'S
STATEMENT, IF HE SAID WE WON'T
INDICT HILLARY CLINTON ON THE
E-MAILS AND THE REPUBLICANS SAID
WAIT A MINUTE.
WE HEARD YOU HAVE A REPORT THAT
SAYS SHE WAS EXTREMELY CARELESS,
WE WANT YOU TO RELEASE THAT, THE
DEMOCRATS WOULD HAVE JUMPED UP
AND DOWN AND SAY NO, NO,
PROSECUTORS DON'T SAY ANYTHING
NEGATIVE ABOUT PEOPLE THEY HAVE
NOT INDICTED.
ALL THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO DO IS
ANNOUNCE NO INDICTMENT.
SUDDENLY EVERYTHING HAS CHANGED.
IT'S THE DEMOCRATS THAT WANT TO
KNOW WHY THERE WASN'T CHARGES.
THEY WANT TO KNOW WHAT IS SPLIT
WAS BETWEEN THOSE THAT WANTED A
CHARGE AND NOT CHARGE IN
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE.
THE LAW DOESN'T AUTHORIZE THAT
TO BE RELEASED.
IF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL WANTS TO
DO IT, THAT'S WITHIN HIS
DISCRETION.
NO COURT SHOULD ORDER THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL IN THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH TO RELEASE
GRAND JURY MATERIAL AND OTHER
MATERIAL THAT THE LEGISLATIVE
BRANCH, CERTAINLY WITHOUT THE
APPROVAL OF THE COURTS.
WE'RE SEEING RAMPANT HYPOCRISY.
IF THE SHOE WERE ON THE OTHER
FOOT, I'M SURE --
>> Sean: YOU KNOW, I AGREE WITH
TREY GOWDY.
I DON'T THINK THEY SHOULD
RELEASE ANY OF IT.
IT WAS DEFINITIVE ON COLLUSION.
IF COLLUSION IS NOT A CRIME
AND -- OKAY.
SO THE ATTORNEY GENERAL AND EVEN
ROD ROSENSTEIN AGREED IN VERY
QUICK ORDER NOT BASED ON ANY
PRINCIPLE WHETHER OR NOT OR
ARGUMENT THAT YOU CAN INDICT A
SITTING PRESIDENT ON THE MERITS,
THEY SAID NO, THIS DOESN'T RISE
TO ANY LEVEL OF INDICTMENT.
GRAND JURY MATERIALS,
ELIMINATING EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE,
SOURCES, INNOCENT PEOPLE.
FRANKLY THE DEMOCRATS SAID WE
SHOULDN'T DO IT.
I THINK MAYBE THEY'RE RIGHT IN
THIS CASE.
LET'S GIVE THEM WHAT THEY
WANTED.
>> YOU KNOW, IT'S AMAZING WHAT A
LITTLE BIT OF GOOD NEWS FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP WILL DO TO MY
DEMOCRATIC COLLEAGUES.
YOU HAVE ADAM SCHIFF, CHAIRMAN
SCHIFF, AS YOU POINTED OUT, WAS
SAYING NO, WE CAN'T RELEASE
ANYTHING THAT IS CLASSIFIED.
WE CAN'T AFFORD TO PUT OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY IN JEOPARDY.
BUT YET HERE HE SAYS I DON'T
CARE WHAT IS IN THERE, RELEASE
IT ALL.
YOU HAVE JERRY NADLER, THAT
SWITCHED AND FLIP-FLOPPED AND
SAID NOW HE'S GOING TO SUBPOENA
THIS, EVEN GRAND JURY MATERIAL.
LISTEN, BOTH SIDES LOOK AT THIS
DIFFERENTLY.
I CAN TELL YOU RIGHT NOW, THIS
IS ALL ABOUT A NARRATIVE, A
NARRATIVE THAT THE DEMOCRATS
HAVE HAD FOR 22 MONTHS THAT WENT
AWAY, BECAUSE THEIR LIES WERE
NOT BORNE OUT IN THE MUELLER
REPORT.
NOW WHAT THEY'RE TRYING TO DO IS
CHANGE THE NARRATIVE AND PICK
AND CHOOSE LITTLE PARTS SO THAT
THEY CAN GO AFTER THE PRESIDENT
AGAIN.
>> Sean: CONGRESSMAN, THERE'S
GOING TO BE CRIMINAL REFERRALS
ISSUED THIS WEEK BY CHAIRMAN
NUNES.
THERE'S GOING TO BE THE
PRESIDENT, I INTERVIEWED LAST
WEEK, THERE WILL BE THE FISA
APPLICATIONS RELEASED.
THERE WILL BE 302s RELEASED AND
GANG OF EIGHT MATERIAL.
WE IDENTIFIED FIVE BUCKETS OF
INFORMATION THAT WILL BE
EXTRAORDINARILY DAMNING, I KNOW
THAT TO BE THE CASE, BASED ON
ALL OF MY SOURCES.
IS THAT A GOOD IDEA?
YOU WANT TRANSPARENCY?
I DON'T THINK THEY WILL LIKE
THAT WHEN THEY COMES OUT.
>> THEY'RE NOT GOING TO LIKE
THAT, SEAN.
I THINK YOU HAVE THE PROFESSOR
ON TONIGHT.
IT'S ABOUT CIVIL LIBERTIES AND
MAKING SURE THOSE CIVIL
LIBERTIES ARE PROTECTED.
IF WE CANNOT COUNT ON OUR
GOVERNMENT TO PROTECT THOSE
PRECIOUS RIGHTS TO PRIVACY
WITHOUT WARRANTS AND WARRANTLESS
SEARCHES, WE HAVE A REAL
PROBLEM.
SOME OF THOSE CRIMINAL REFERRALS
ARE JUSTIFIED.
CERTAINLY SOME OF THE
DECLASSIFICATION THAT GETS TO
THE BOTTOM IT IS JUSTIFIED.
AT THE SAME TIME, WE HAVE TO
PROTECT OUR NATIONAL SECURITY
INTERESTS.
>> Sean: PROFESSOR, I WANT TO
ASK YOU THIS.
THEY'RE GOING TO CALL BACK NOW
TO REINTERVIEW -- THEY DON'T
MAKE A LOT OF PEOPLE.
A GOOD ATTORNEY IN WASHINGTON,
I'M IMAGINING, IS CLOSE TO
$1,000 AN HOUR.
FOR THE SAME QUESTIONS?
HOW MANY TIMES MUST PEOPLE BE
HARASSED LIKE THIS?
WHY CAN'T THEY JUST SAY I PLEAD
THE FIFTH?
I STAND BY MY PRIOR TIME.
>> FOR MANY PEOPLE, THAT IMPLIES
GUILT.
REMEMBER WHEN THE SENATE DID
THAT IN THE MCCARTHY PERIOD, THE
COURTS PUT AN END TO IT.
YOU CAN'T JUST HARASS PEOPLE AND
CALL PEOPLE IN ORDER TO EXPOSE
THEM.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE A --
>> Sean: WHAT IF THEY
MISREMEMBER SOMETHING FROM
TESTIMONY 1 1/2 YEARS AGO?
THEY DECIDE --
>> THERE'S NO QUESTION, PERJURY
TRAPS CAN BE FALLEN INTO BY
INNOCENT PEOPLE.
IF AN INNOCENT PERSON TESTIFIES
TO AND THE PROSECUTORS CHOOSE TO
BELIEVE THE OTHER PERSON, YOU
FALL INTO A PERJURY TRAP.
THAT'S WHY THE PRESIDENT WAS
RIGHT NOT TO TESTIFY TO MUELLER.
CIVIL LIBERTARIANS OUGHT TO BE
CONCERNED ABOUT EXPOSING TO
CRITICISM ONE-SIDED REPORT,
WHICH ONLY SAW ONE SIDE OF THE
STORY AND DIDN'T RESULT IN
INDICTMENTS.
THAT'S TRADITIONALLY NOT DONE.
AT LEAST THE COURTS HAVE TO BE
ASKED TO COME IN AND DECIDE WHAT
CAN BE SHOWN HAND WHAT CAN'T
THAT COME FROM GRAND JURIES.
LET'S HAVE THE SAME --
>> Sean: MAYBE DEMOCRATS MIGHT
WANT TO GIVE UP ON THE SAME
INVESTIGATION.
THEY HAD THE FBI INVESTIGATION,
NO COLLUSION, NO OBSTRUCTION.
GIVE IT UP.